foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
quack
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome
to NFL bets that we love on Thanksgiving
guys it's the Thanksgiving special how
we feeling today it's Thanksgiving what
is our favorite Thanksgiving Foods what
is something that we are looking forward
to eating today
I am a big stuffing guy and I know we
put out a br betting odds graphic for a
ranking Thanksgiving foods and stuffing
at plus 850 is one of the worst lines of
the year so I would hammer that all day
long
yeah but there's Great Value there
there's Great Value so it's a great bet
no it's a great bet absolutely great
value love the plus 800 on the stuffing
uh Ryan talk to us I see I see the it
there's a beam there's a beam on you
today Ryan That's Good Vibes that is
great vibes from the heavens above
it's great it's great Vibes for the rest
of the day it's not good vibes for when
it eventually hits me in the eyes so you
know we'll see
hey we're we're bringing the positives
though uh but it's a I I'm telling you
guys it's like minus 10 000 that I eat a
pie today a sweet potato pie because
that is by far my favorite dish
it's dessert guys it's the sweet potato
pie for Thanksgiving my mom makes the
best but we are here for one reason and
one reason only the man next to me I
call him the man the myth the legend his
name is Sam Richmond my name is uh Greg
Ivory and then to the next of Sam
besides Sam is producer Ryan he is the
gatekeeper of the chat he is the one
that connects us to you guys uh Sam he's
giving out his Best Bets today we're not
talking six but Sam got some juicy juicy
bets for you guys drop the locks in the
chat we'll be grading your picks at the
end of the show Ryan we're going to send
you back to the chat because it's time
to get down to business
Sam we know that you have six bets
usually but today we're talking two
that's very generous on Thanksgiving so
I'm not even going to put the clock on
you today bro I'm not going to put the
clock on you you got all the time in the
world you need let's talk your picks
take it away Sam
all right well if I got all the time I
might as well stretch this out spend 25
minutes talking about this game no I'll
still be brief
um my favorite pick of the day is the
Patriots plus three I think they're down
to two and a half in most spots but it's
like a juice two and a half so you can
still get plus three that is still
pretty decent number anything around
minus 120 I like but yeah no I really
like the Pats today I think the the
biggest thing for me and we talked about
this last week is is I just think the
Minnesota Vikings are huge frauds and uh
we said that last week and we took the
Cowboys and obviously that take was sort
of even further validated
um but yeah I just I just think that's a
very average football team and obviously
Greg you know I'm a huge dvoa guy and
the Vikings currently and dvoa rank 24th
overall that is one spot better than the
poverty Denver Broncos that's where the
Vikings are so I just don't think their
win loss record is reflective at all
about how good they are the the pads of
the other hand now have the number one
defense in the league betting on Mac
Jones obviously scary but that defense
is really really strong I know it's
against Zach Wilson but they limited
that team that jet scene last week to
like 2.7 inches per play in the second
half so if you're giving me three points
you're giving me the Pats defense and
you're giving me an overrated Vikings
team I'm taking it all day long so that
is my best bet of the day
I like that one Sam I like that one a
lot you touched on a major major
important Point New England that defense
I I own them in my fantasy league so I
know firsthand that defense is lethal
this year they've been putting up a lot
of points uh Sam I would have asked you
some questions I would have asked you
some questions about the Vikings playing
at home historic like throughout the
years they play better at home than on
the road so uh
but after last week but after last week
and how they got
embarrassed at home
I can't even say that no more can't say
that no more let's go to the chat though
let's go to the chat Ryan come on in my
man Sam just dropped his best bet of the
day rocking with New England Bill
Belichick and that Patriots defense talk
to us what are the people talking about
well Sam do you think they like the pick
I don't think so I think the the Vikings
are definitely the more popular side I
think people are they're better on the
bounce back yeah uh so Rico says very
amateur take just shows you're not
actually watching the games did you
watch the Patriots last week we're
supposed to trust that team with a
million question marks Did you watch the
defense again they gave up like 20 yards
in the second half I get it Mac Jones is
not good I'm not saying Mac Jones is
good but the Vikings are also not good
and the Patriots have the best unit on
the field with the defense I gotta say
this though Ryan before you get back in
there amateur picks do you know Sam's
record bro I don't don't call him the
man the myth the legend for no reason
like put some respect on that man's name
all right Ryan go ahead go back to go go
ahead back to the chat I just have to
say that yeah you know I I feel you uh
the onions our guy sitting here every
week uh great pick don't doubt the Mac
attack I'm starting to feel like the
people who are in here every week just
start are starting to understand that we
win it doesn't matter you went diving
one last week we hit the anytime TD on
Justin you know what I'll stop I'll stop
okay hey don't tell him too much Sam
Real G's moving side it's like with Zion
it's up for this it's to them to know
what's going on like you know what I'm
saying we're just going to continue to
win Ryan let's talk about the chat a
little bit more and then we're going to
get to Sam's next pick
yeah well Donnie and shoved back into
defense Sam and said y'all were clowning
his uh Cowboys pick last week and look
what happened
look it drops the mic send that guy a
hoodie if he doesn't have one
if you said something positive about me
you would get the free stuff that's
pretty much
hey should we move on
let's do it let's do it let's move on
all right here we go uh let's send Ryan
back to the chat
um Sam one pick down one more to go no
time clock no time clock take as much
time as you need brother go ahead take
it away this is nice only having two
picks to go out um no second pick I'm
taking this is for the first game I'm
taking the bills minus nine and a half
um I like this line seam I think they're
they're getting a lot better obviously
they've won three games in a row but to
me this is just a step above their
weight class uh with the bills and uh I
think people are kind of like starting
to like the bills are not getting talked
about as much anymore all the talk is
about Mahomes and the Chiefs and boom's
going to win MVP Chiefs are gonna win
the Super Bowl but to me I still have
this bill's team as the best team in the
league they do pretty much everything at
an elite level and I think this is a
really good spot for them to sort of
remind everyone how good they are and as
much as the lions are improving their
defense is still pretty poor they're
still 28th and defensive dboa which when
you're facing Josh Allen Stefan Diggs
and that Bill's offense you're you're
going to be in a long in for a long day
so I'm selling High a bit on the Lions
even though I like them I'm sort of
buying low on the bills trying to prove
everyone that they're still the best
team in the league
um and I'm picking them to cover the
nine and a half today
oh Sam oh I mean double digit uh nine
and a half they gotta win by ten double
digits spread yeah a lot of points a lot
of points he's rocking with the bills
bills I mean they have been playing well
this year they have been playing well so
I like it I like it I like it you know I
all my confidence is in Sam the man the
myth the legend uh but let's bring in
producer Ryan let's bring in producer
Ryan uh because we want to talk about
the chat we want to see what they are
talking about I love when we bring in
producer Ryan and then just the beam
Ryan every bet that you're gonna place
today is gonna hit don't go placing 10
11 12 bets go place like one two three I
got two I'm telling you the Vibes The
Vibes are telling me that they're gonna
hit
well that's not good because I already
not good for Sam at least because I
already placed the bed on lions plus
nine and a half so we don't we don't
like that bad karma immediately uh at
Tennessee Titans uh I doubt this is the
Titans uh Team official page but who
knows maybe it is uh under in the game
is a safe bet seven to three at half I
kind of wanted to shout that out because
if it is seven to three at half I would
like to remember that and I'm gonna be
upset that I think I'm at the Pats game
are you talking about the the bills are
scoring seven points
yeah I think he likes yeah I that total
is ridiculous
I've been getting a lot of Intel in my
DMs a lot of people telling me that to
bet the under in that game but like I
don't know is that the play
I mean we're under hitting I don't I
just don't know if I see a seven to
three halftime score I'll say that yeah
I don't see that I don't see that at all
yeah uh let's see uh Dylan Leisure says
gotta trust the goat now
there is no goat in the Lions Bills game
so I'm assuming he's talking about you
Sam that would be more Belichick or he's
talking about Bell track uh I mean yes
we have moved down for the if there are
still Patriots takes in the chat we
already moved on like I get it but we
moved on so I hope not
uh and then we've got uh Vincent uh
Arena Dalton Schultz over 37.5 receiving
yards not the game that you were talking
about but uh he's been dropping it in
here incessantly so I'm gonna assume
that's his lock of the day guys you just
want to talk Cowboys so that's fair I
mentioned a little bit yeah
there it is the chat the chat is uh
giving us takes as always but Sam Ryan
and I are gonna help you out you gave
two picks we're gonna help you out and
give you some pics of our on Ryan you
know what to do let's pull up DraftKings
and we about to get right to it Ryan if
you click on
um let's start with the Buffalo Bills
Detroit Lions game click on it and then
you know we're gonna go to alternate
spreads here because I'm gonna build a
parlay that uh that should not lose that
should not lose uh Ryan let's go to the
actually go to the totals please not the
totals there it is and let's go to over
46 points over 46 points I can see this
one happening uh you know 46 points 23
points by each team I see uh Sam has the
bills winning by 10. so do the math I
can see this one actually happening so
we're going to lock that one in all
right Ryan let's go back to the to the
matchups
let's go back over to the matchups and
uh
I'll give you guys another another
alternate spread you can go to Dallas
yeah go to go there go to Dallas let's
go to an alternate spreads so Cowboys
minus 17.
no no no no no no no no I wish I wish I
wish I wish I you know
could put that on this ticket but I want
this ticket to actually win Ryan so
we're gonna go with Cowboys minus three
Cowboys minus three
Cowboys minus three I'm gonna lock that
one in and then Ryan go ahead back up to
the matchups we're gonna get the plus
odds here are we gonna get to plus odds
here damn watch watch and see you watch
and see we are gonna get we might get to
plus odds I don't want to make any
promises you know DraftKings uh they
they odd change odds change but we
should get to plus odds uh Ryan let's
lock in Minnesota plus seven Sam you can
win and I can win we both can win we can
meddle it there it is we got to plus
odds plus 108 a this is as good as like
even money a little better and you got
action throughout the whole day there it
is
look at it ponder it and go bet it in
that's my bet Ryan what are you over
there Brewing up for us
all right so my bet is very simple for
today
I'm not gonna go against Sam and his
Bills pick we'll we'll just agree to
disagree there my other pick for today
is the Dallas Cowboys team total over 27
and a half this team I believe has
averaged 35 points in their last four
games the Giants as Sam has said I think
this is a direct quote from Sam our
stinky poo and they are not a good team
they smell like poop they are poop so I
think the cowboy is just absolutely
demolish them today uh
that's that's it I think over 27 and a
half they're gonna score a lot of points
now you can say well why not just
Cowboys minus 10. the Cowboys don't
cover on Thanksgiving I have lived that
nightmare enough times in my life that I
just think they're gonna score a lot of
points so I'll bet that
if we don't write about your analysis
there uh I'm gonna be very upset so that
that was well done that was a Master
Class
attack you
Ryan's locking it in Ryan let's talk to
the chat what are the people talking
about
uh we've got Ben the goat saying uh
Stefan Diggs over seven and a half
receptions is a lock
um how do you guys feel about that
I like it I like it too I like it I
think you're I think the only concern
with Bill's props is if they get up big
late and then run it on a poverty run
defense and just sort of like knock out
there that's a concern for me too with
you know getting back door covered but
um but I do think he's gonna have a big
game for sure
uh jacum says he likes uh Lions plus
nine and a half and Giants plus nine and
a half
like we've talked we've talked about the
bills the bills Lions game a lot do you
like do you see this Cowboy Giants game
being close enough where they can cover
that
I don't I I personally don't I I you
know as you said I think the Giants are
Stinky Poo
um so no I I I do not expect to me I I
like that I like that cowboy side the
line just got too out of hand for me to
to play it at double digits but um but I
do I do lean that way okay uh always
parlayian with a straight pick Daniel
Jones two plus interceptions
hasn't been throwing them a lot though
Big Island
yes I mean last week Greg called it a
peninsula
I think we learned we learned our lesson
I won't say but uh not that I Told You
So guy but yeah uh and then we'll go
last one here uh Jimmy Choo uh Pat's
moneyline
every now and against him you get
somebody
yeah it says forget about that I like I
like that but I also like Greg's Vikings
plus seven because I don't think the
Pats aren't going to blow them out
because they have a bad offense
um I think they can win I think they can
cover but I think it's going to be a
three-point game so I I just want to say
I don't hate Greg's parlay at all we're
riding together we're family hey that's
that's love brother that's love uh let's
build another one let's why not let's
build another when we're talking parlays
let's build another we need you guys
help we need your help to build it
anytime touchdown parlay Ryan tell the
people what we need from them
so we need a pick of who's going to
score touchdown uh from every single
game so like we had said we kind of want
action throughout the entire day
obviously this is dependent on each leg
hitting but a touchdown score from the
bills Alliance a touchdown score from
the Giants Cowboys and a touchdown score
from Pat's Vikings the total is very low
in that last game if you like no
touchdown being scored I consider it
we'll talk about it but drop your drop
your take in the chat uh let us know and
we're gonna build it together now
let's let's do it let I mean what let's
start building
let's go
uh I'm not gonna lie guys
whenever I think we made a rule whenever
I see JJ Justin Jefferson plus money
we gotta lock it in I was looking
yesterday he was plus money not sure
he's plus money this time uh
one game at a time Greg one game I'm
sorry I'm sorry I dropped the gun I
jumped the gun I apologize I apologize
but I just had to get that out there I I
wanted to let the audience know Justin
Jefferson is plus money the score
touchdown today sorry Ryan let's let's
that's a good mood to try and get the
crowd in our favor to put that in the
chat because we're gonna let them build
it so I I respect the hell out of that
move
uh hey Sam Light Years light years as as
uh as as the Warriors would say light
years but let's let's uh let's get into
this we got Stefan Diggs Devin
Singletary Jamal Williams Josh Allen
Gabriel Davis
Amman Ross Saint Brown he's really good
uh I don't know who's that that is at
the bottom but uh are we getting into
the comments uh are we getting into the
chat should I hop in here
we got BR fans saying Josh Allen I'm
gonna stick to we got a lot of takes so
right now we're just gonna stick to
Bill's Lions uh I see Josh Allen and
then I see from Jacob Maples uh Jamal
Williams anytime tud is too easy
I like Williams he got what three
touchdowns last week I don't know he's
like always getting in the end zone man
I'm car says
in Jamal
Pollard JJ and Jamal so Jamal Williams
um he's locking that one in I I you guys
aren't saying anything I'm not getting
any reactions so I'm I'm Gonna Keep keep
going uh I hate that I don't hate that
at all Sam doesn't hey the chat is
jumping
I see Williams I see Williams again
let's let's lock in Jamal Williams Chef
Boyardee Jeff Chef Boyardee says Diggs
and Williams but this is the second time
I've seen Jamal Williams so you guys
want to lock it in are you guys feeling
confident about that one
I like that yeah I do like that yeah
let's lock that one in all right Ryan
you seem skeptical are you skeptical I
always prefer it's not too late it's not
too late I just always prefer to take a
touchdown score from the team that I
think is going to win the game you know
besides digs
well there is a lot of Dave's love in
here I like the Singletary somebody the
onions dropped uh Devin Singletary and I
I don't hate that I mean he's been
getting the ball a lot if we want to
it's I I'm a man of the people if we
want to do Jamal Williams we will do
Jamal Williams and we'll and we'll ride
into the four o'clock game I'm cool with
it Greg Greg you're the tiebreaker
single Terrier Williams
I see three people just said Jamal
Williams in the last two seconds
all right let's let's [ __ ] in Williams
uh and then let's go to the next one
the next game is Giants Cowboys Ryan
yes sir
Giants Cowboys I've been seeing a lot of
Pollard Jose Parra says uh Diggs Barkley
Pollard uh I also say see KT Pegasus
says Zeke
KT Pegasus is saying Zeke uh
one I I see the the comments are jumping
guys literally the comments are jumping
uh Ryan digging here if you see anything
I also see Pollard from Al Mendoza or
Elementos Sam what's your take on Paula
do you think he's a good and he said as
values that one minus 135. so I love
Pollard and I think he's obviously the
best running back on that team I just
have flashbacks to last week where he
got stuffed now I know he ended up
scoring twice but he got stuff twice at
the goal line and they bring in Zeke to
finish the drill and get in the end zone
they like Zeke in those short yardage
situations so if you're getting a
Pollard TD and I defer to our Cowboys
expert Ryan you kind of need like a big
play and that's a little scary to rely
on whereas Zeke you you know pass
interference in the end zone one yarder
like I I don't know Ryan what's your
take there you're you're a Cowboys Guru
yeah I love what uh Zeke has become in
this offense which is like you said kind
of like that short yardage expert the
guy who's gonna run you over and then
you hand the ball to Pollard when you
need to blow past the entire defense so
I agree with you I think in those
shortyard situations it's going to be
Zeke I will say
I love a play here and it's not going to
be one of the more popular ones and
Vincent uh Arena also said the same
thing Dalton Schultz Dalton Schultz plus
215 here
Dak loves him some Dalton Schultz loves
Donald Schultz and if we want to get
this really juicy if we want to get
distracted by a certain GIF in the chat
um but I'm back 10 to 1 11-1 yeah I know
it's the people love Zeke we can do that
I'm not against it it's plus 100 we can
do that all I'm saying is this is my the
case I'm making and I want to give uh
Vincent in the chat you know some love
too for Dalton Schultz but you know it's
up to you guys Zeke okay all right yeah
can I just can I also throw out one
other suggestion we haven't talked about
this at all like giants poverty no
offensive weapons besides one man who
has the quads of 10 men
saquan Barkley like if they score a
touchdown they score one or two it's
probably going to be saquon and I like
the Cowboys just have so many more
weapons Pollard CD Zeke Schultz
um there's so many guys who get it that
I don't know like if you're if you're
wrong with sequence I don't know it
doesn't seem like the the chat is really
into saquon but I do think he's
interested I just want to throw it out
there
no he's definitely interesting
definitely interesting I mean I'm not
gonna lie I've been quiet looking at
this chat for the last like couple
minutes I'm seeing a lot of Zeke love
Sam makes a great great point if the
Giants do get in the end zone it's more
than likely going to be Saigon Barkley
We Are Men of the people so if the chat
is more on Zeke and I I do like the path
for Zeke I'm willing to do that I just
want to open it up I wanted to see what
the chat would say
um it's a Cowboys uh chat in here also
if like we're gonna take the team that's
May score 35 points then like yeah all
right we'll just do it yeah I like it
it's plus money
I know maybe he'll jump in the the
Salvation Army bucket again that was
pretty legendary hey we gotta go JJ here
like there's no we wonder if Greg is
blocking out the chat for this one
we like literally have to go Justin
Jefferson I like it no I'll read some
takes though I mean I I will read some
takes uh people in the chat are still
talking about uh
I see oh you know what someone did just
drop and it just needs to be mentioned
he's not gonna we're not taking it but a
lot of vanilla Vic love in the chat
which is just an unbelievable nickname
for Daniel Jones like that's just so
good
I do see the vanilla Vic in the comments
uh
also Pollard is getting some love but I
think we made a good decision with Zeke
I'm I want JJ guys I want JJ uh
commenters you guys let us know
I want JJ like he had a absolutely
terrible game last week he's been
bawling this year every week he didn't
do well he performed the next week
they're going to look to try to get him
going I know he's facing that Patriots
defense I know what Bill Belichick does
to opposing players star players
but JJ's plus money and we made a rule
at the beginning of the year like if
JJ's plus money we're gonna take it but
I'm I'm in the comments I see Michael
Bowen says JJ for sure uh twin number
two says Jetta so much JJ love so much
boy 22 says JJ two TVs uh Al Mendoza
says listen to Greg give us JJ uh only
only J Ross says JJ is overdue like do I
need to keep going or should we just
call I will say I think you're
conveniently skipping over uh Vincent
urina and always parliam who want TJ
Hawkinson I I maybe I needed to go to
tight end you maybe I needed to I don't
know what you're doing there yeah yeah
look
it's Jason
it's JJ you're seriously sitting up here
trying to tell us to bet TJ Hawkinson
over JJ he gets the Red Zone targets I
don't know what to tell you guys plus
money JJ
let me just say look at what it would do
here
I mean
11-1
but you can you can sprinkle that with
Hawk and then after the game you can you
can come right yeah right come back
let's lock in JJ let's let's go guys
because we got more to talk about
what's the juice on this one this is
plus 739 so let's go over the plays
again we decided on Jamal Williams minus
105 Zeke at plus 100 and Justin
Jefferson against by Will at plus 115.
uh to get to plus 739 so
this should hit this should hit
again
this one should hit make sure you guys
tell us on DraftKings so you can get
rich too we got six quarterbacks in the
mix today guys let's talk their passing
yards over under Ryan talk to us what
are the lines
all right so first up we'll start out
with the early game Josh Allen
286. 286 and a half passing yards over
or under
my man Sam's a big dvoa guy and he he
dropped the defense
for the Lions he dropped their dvoa
earlier in the show I forget what it was
I think it was like 24. 28 28. Sam why
do I feel like you knew that on the top
of your head bro you like know the bboa
I did I gotta you like take people
behind the curtain I gotta research my
stats and information I got to memorize
it's a long process I was gonna say bro
you probably know the dvoa dvoa power
rankings by heart but I love it I
absolutely love it it's up to two Ryan's
Cowboys up to two right behind the bills
there we go
the fact that he knows this Raven's at
three Raven's at Three Eagles at four I
don't know who's at five yeah I don't
know it might be Casey I don't know I
don't know I I can just I I love that
the you know the chat I'm sure is all in
on dvoa as well yeah yeah what people
came for this is yeah that's what they
want to talk about right exactly okay
Jared Goff 246 and a half passing yards
over and under
oh I could see him get in there in
garbage time yeah that's what I was
gonna say I was gonna say over because
they're gonna be behind so he's going to
be throwing the ball a lot also look at
his completions total
got a scoop there because of that reason
they're going to be behind so they're
going to be throwing the ball uh look at
this completions total but I'm going
over here
okay uh Dak Prescott 256 and a half
passing yards over or under
under
yeah
because he's going to be giving the ball
to Pollard and Zeke all day and that's
how that's how we win well yeah I mean
they're going to be up 28 and it's going
to be like why why are we passing you
know so uh Finbar uh agrees under uh
said Logan under uh it's a big it's a
big under day uh the one
jumping in here Bill's team total under
32 and a half uh not what the segment is
but I appreciate the luck regardless uh
jackham Goff over
so uh we have some
a lot of people love this bill's Lions
game I'm kind of surprised by it but
also I don't know the lines the first
game of Thanksgiving we all yeah we
gotta bet it that's true it is true it's
just like I feel like the Lions don't
usually like it's not really a draw on
Thanksgiving but you know they're bad
the lions are now the trendy team
because Dan Campbell drinks 37
000 ounces of coffee a day no Dan
Campbell slender here I'm a dad we're
we're a Dan Campbell family uh Daniel
Jones
195 and a half passing yards over under
guys
under
yeah that defense her defense is gonna
keep him under in my opinion all right I
think he's got to throw a lot I would go
over but Kirk Cousins 247 and a half
passing yards over under
but uh but Jefferson Gets In The End
Zone
I agree defense
all right Mac Jones
230 and a half passing yards over or
under
ooh
he still had passing yards and he wasn't
scoring but he had passwords yeah Fair
um
I I'm gonna go over I'm gonna go over
let's go to the chat real quickly Ryan
let's see what they're talking about
um and we're gonna move on
uh KT Pegasus I appreciate the troll of
this comment uh I'm late but I like
Kenny Gallade touchdown I don't think
Kenny Gallade has caught a pass
that's so sad
Kitty dial today was a beast a couple
years ago I had him on my fantasy team
going crazy but
yeah the Mad Trafford effect uh the
onions over on Daniel Jones because they
should be uh be behind meaning they're
gonna have to throw a lot uh agree that
was my take as well
um said Logan Daniel Jones to throw an
interception
I'd love to know the odds on these
because you say something like that and
I immediately think it's probably like
minus 280. so you can't do it that's
true yeah definitely you need uh one
more Ryan one more and then we're gonna
move
yeah and then said Logan coming in here
dropping again uh under all day for Kirk
and an interception so nice little
parlay all right
we got something else for you guys if
you guys like betting QB props we cooked
up a Thanksgiving special for you over
nine and a half total passing touchdowns
boosted from minus 110 to plus
125. that's all games all quarterbacks
combined Sam Ryan
you guys like this one are you telling
it kind of feels like a low number you
got six quarterbacks to get 10. have
plus money
it does seem kind of low to me Ryan I
see skeptical a skeptical kind of face
on a look on your face
well I mean the quarterbacks that we
just mentioned are not particularly good
but like Sam said it is a low number and
it's at plus money so yes I I of course
am taking that
Ryan's rocking with it all right if
you're in the BR app you know we asked
you to go and vote and build a
Thanksgiving parlay and now we're going
to grade it Ryan give us those results
please
yeah so shocker uh the community picked
the favorites uh in each of these games
so let's go here and let's build this
parlay
um but
I had kind of uh I teased it a little
bit before but they like the bills to
cover so bills at
minus nine and a half
uh the Dallas Cowboys
minus 10
and the Minnesota Vikings
fading Sam
so if you parlay that it is at it's a
three legger that ends up at plus
581. so there's juice there
well how do you guys feel about it
I mean like the bills yeah obviously
like the Bills Cowboys I that would be
my Lean Like I said I I that would be
where I would lean if that the line
obviously opened at like seven seven and
a half it was still there I would have
taken it but it just moved out of range
for me once you hit the double digits
apart but I do think the Giants are
really not good and the Cowboys are one
of the best teams in the league so I
would take that obviously I'm on the
path so I do think the last leg loses
here but I'm I'm used to going
head-to-head with the community I
embrace it I love it I love you
community even though you tell me every
one of my picks sucks so
um I wish you the best today
um but I think you're losing on the last
leg I'm sorry to say
wish you guys nothing but the best uh
I'll give it a B for for Vibes giving it
a B for Vibes but uh yeah
all favorites all favorites like we
gotta we gotta figure it out you know
can't bet the favorite it is funny when
like when we do these Community parlays
and then everyone in the community is
like this parlay sucks and it's like no
this is your parlay you voted for it so
don't don't get mad at us exactly you
know if you're in the chat being like
too many favorites I want to see some
underdogs then vote next time and vote
for The Underdogs
Sam you make a great great great great
Point all right we're going to grade
some of your picks but first our very
own Natalie body had a chance to catch
up
with the director from DraftKings
Sportsbook my man Johnny avello let's
take a look
we're with the director of the
DraftKings sports book Johnny ovello
thanks so much for joining us Johnny
hey Natalie good to see you yeah glad to
have you back let's just jump right into
it we're gonna go with the Super Bowl
question first look ahead what team has
the most bets on it right now to win the
Super Bowl
oh that would be the uh Buffalo Bills uh
who have taken over 20 of the action and
the bets
um the highest priced on Natalie could
have gotten on them was around a six to
one range or so so they've been
relatively a short price all season
all right not too surprised about the
bills but I'm curious who have you
noticed become the public team this year
just one that the public absolutely
loves are always on their side
well I'm gonna mention the same team
that's been the top magnet for the last
three seasons and that's the Kansas City
Chiefs but I will give you one team that
is surprisingly in the BET mix this year
that is the Cincinnati Bengals uh the
Bettors don't forget when you've been
really good to them and last year they
were 14-7 against the number and so far
this year they're seven and three so
returns are good
I'm one of those betters that was a bit
partial so you guys have been taking my
money too but we're gonna throw it back
a little bit earlier this spring you
told us one of the popular MVP
candidates was Jalen hurts currently as
the third best odds to win it are you
getting nervous Johnny
um we take a pretty big hit if Hertz
does win the award uh we're in like
seven figure territory wow so nervous
Natalie nah I'm not nervous this is this
is why we're in the business but to have
these type of offerings to allow it to
our clientele uh and for chances for
them to make scores uh remember though
there is still a few participants who
may be standing in Mr hurt's way the
likes of Mahomes and Allen Intuit so
it's not locked up yet
absolutely not you're right but on a
contrary I want to talk big wins and
losses so what game this season has been
the biggest hit or loss for DraftKings
and vice versa which was the biggest win
for DraftKings
oh the the biggest loss uh that was that
Chief set the Bucks in early October uh
late that was a late start isolated game
chiefs were just pounding that one as a
small Underdog and they were plus 120 on
the money line they went on to win that
one 41-31 and of course then the total
went over to compound the loss
um the best game for the house so far
was open in night that was Monday Night
Football we opened up Seattle of about a
field goal favorite and that was a
couple months before the season started
remember we you know we put up those
lines quite early and we closed the
Broncos a six and a half Point favorite
that's a lot of movement Natalie for an
NFL game and you know fortunately for us
we got there Seattle won that game 17-16
yeah I'm not surprised there that makes
sense was such an early line but now
we're already at Thanksgiving week it's
flown by from that first game to now we
know Thanksgiving is supposed to be time
with family but we all sneak away to vet
I'll be vetting that day so I'm just
curious Johnny what is the perspective
what the handle looks like on
Thanksgiving is that the single biggest
day of the regular season for DraftKings
that's certainly a big day for us uh and
what makes some of these Thanksgiving
football days bigger than others are the
match-ups and what type of season are
the Cowboys and the lions having because
they're in the games uh you know every
year
um well to kick it off this year the
kick off the day will have the resurgent
Lions playing the popular bills uh game
two there's a class between the New York
Giants and the Cowboys both at seven and
three and then the night cap where the
popular New England Patriots uh square
off against eight and two Vikings so
I don't think we could have scripted it
any better sounds like it's going to be
big handled to me
speaking of those Thanksgiving games I'm
just curious you have any wild crazy
betting stories surrounding Thanksgiving
well you know I've been at DK now since
2018
and the favorites on Thanksgiving Day
have probably won just over 50 percent
you know nothing nothing too crazy on
those days but in my tenure at the
retail Las Vegas sports books there have
been some Thanksgiving blood bass uh
like around maybe two week 2018
2012 somewhere in those in that time
frame they were days when all the chalk
won and all the games went over just
absolutely awful days for the bookmaker
but great days for the public I'm sure
those were fun for Bettors but Johnny
thanks so
thanks to talk to you and I hope you
have a fantastic Thanksgiving
you're welcome and thank you Natalie
it is time to drop your picks in the
chat and Sam and I will great them Ryan
talk to us you are our chat Whisperer
um talk to us what are the people like
what are they talking about
me and Sam were we we're known to be
some some hard graders sometime but it's
Thanksgiving it's it's a it's a it's a
day of thanks it's a day of giving so I
might be generous today Sam I don't know
about you
again you can't get an A unless you're
on the exact same pick as me but I will
try and be a little more generous than
usual That's Good Vibes Greg
Ryan
all right so we've got the onions saying
Gabe Davis over he said 50 yards and
then he apologized for not looking at
the odds so the chat is starting to
understand we need we need the odds
luckily for him I am on DraftKings all
of the time uh and I see it's at 59 and
a half so I'm gonna assume that's what
he meant over or over 59 and a half is
the play What's the grid
you give me like a B minus I think that
like Gabe Davis obviously extremely
talented I feel like his yardage totals
aren't super consistent and sometimes he
doesn't get a ton of targets and they go
to dig so it's just it's tough to rely
on him that's why I know there's a lot
of talk for him being involved in the
parlay but it's just super talented
tough tough to rely on the consistency
yeah I agree Sam super talented super he
can get this in one play you know
especially with his quarterback uh but
it's inconsistency it's pretty much due
to Stefan Diggs and the other Playmakers
on that offense
um so I'll give it a b I'll give it a b
simply because it can happen it can
happen and we're being generous today so
give it a Beat
okay uh Vincent urina Dalton Schultz
over he said 37 and a half receiving
yards I'm seeing 38 and a half now uh
it's minus 145.
well I upgrade that one Ryan yeah I was
just about to say
yeah that's that's an honor roll kind of
kind of bet like that you're putting
that that that's a straight A's you're
putting that on the fridge uh your
parents are getting a bumper sticker
that's that's an awesome bet I love love
love when Dalton Schultz yards are that
low because Dak Prescott loves himself
some Dalton Schultz and like I said the
Giants
stick so I like it it's not exactly what
I said but you know
I don't think uh all right
um
all right we got a parlay
M Menino
Lions money line Giants plus 11 Vikings
money line
give me a second to concoct what those
odds are but you guys Talk Amongst
yourselves
I mean I like swinging for the fences
but I just don't I do not see the Lions
being the bills I don't know Greg Greg
if you have a different take yeah now
the odds on that is probably crazy but I
I just don't see it happening you know
uh maybe I could be wrong but
I don't see it happen so if uh if I was
the greatest and we are being generous
I'll give this a d
um and that's me being generous
very generous yeah yeah
s are 12-1
yeah donations
um all right so let's get back let's get
back to the chat uh always parlay and
said LOL hell no Lions can't pull this
off today Good Vibes always love that
um
let's see let's see let's see uh okay J
Koran Dallas Giants over 45 and a half
I just don't know if the Giants are
gonna be able to score enough points
against that defense like
to to get over uh it over that number so
I don't I don't know I I give it a c
that one's a tough one like we we know
the Cowboys are going to score even you
bet that Ryan you that was one of your
bets we know they're going to put up
points but it's the giant is going to
put up points and that's what we're
going to need Cowboys defense
is the Cowboys defense Ryan says Diggs
is on the island I think he's on the
peninsula uh but it's something like
that that's tough
uh well Kirk Cousins didn't have any
time last week it wasn't I'm not going
to go there we have to move on the show
it was the offensive line fought that's
why JJ didn't go off it was off into
line fall but anyway I'll give this
person a beat I don't even know what
their bet was I got sidetracked but be
forget about it
[Laughter]
uh
this is an interesting one M baldeo Matt
Breda over 10 and a half rushing yards
really
to spell 49ers yeah
dispel saquon Barton
burrito brita's he's a spark I'm not
he's good no he just he's good
yeah I
don't hate it either I don't hate that
either I mean yeah yeah
it's minus 120.
oh my God I like that Greg might play
that great Greg's looking like he's
about to place that Sam yeah Mike I just
wait Brita so like I'm not a big Giant's
father he he's actually the spell guy
for say Quan Barkley first guy coming in
yeah he's the number two I will say I I
have to by principle take the under I
have I have personal beef with Matt
brada back to my reporting days I asked
him about a injury that it was the wrong
injury it was his hamstring not his
ankle he got mad at me embarrassed me
all good I'm taking the under uh this is
an F
not evaporate again well fair fair in
those instances
yeah maybe I should have had the right
injury that that's what the people say
but regardless
um all right Stefan Diggs from uh dizzy
bands Stefan takes anytime touchdown
we saw it's minus 180. maybe if the
price is that high because it's a lock
but what do you guys maybe do digs
anytime TD bills moneyline parlay to get
that digs number down a little bit
out there
throwing it out there
all right Ryan I I'm I'm ready to go eat
I'm ready to go watch some games we've
been on for a little bit have fun with
y'all Sam dropped his picks Ryan dropped
some pics I dropped up some pics from
Parlay uh we've been waiting over here
so man it's up to y'all to pay attention
because at the end of the day Real G's
moving silence like lasagna like I
always say my name is Greg Ivy next to
me is Sam the man the myth the legend
you got to say it just like that
everybody the man the myth the legend
Sam Richmond and next to him is producer
Ryan we are out of here but to take us
out here's Natalie beaudet talking with
Mike Golic Jr enjoy your Thanksgiving
and see you Sunday we out this thing
peace
we're with NFL expert and host of the
Gojo podcast from DraftKings Mike Golic
Jr thanks so much for joining us Mike
thanks for having me really appreciate
it excited to talk some ball heading
into Thanksgiving what better oh yeah
always a good time but let's just go
ahead and get right into it so we've got
the Lions Giants and Patriots as
underdogs today which dog do you think
can win outright
I think I'd probably have to look at New
England on this front and so much of
that is off the strength of what that
defense has been able to do number you
know in the end right now in the NFL top
five in interceptions top five in sacks
number one in opposing completion
percentage allowed they've been a
nightmare for opposing quarterbacks so
we saw this Minnesota team finally get
their cage rattled a bit against Dallas
I don't think they're as bad as that
game showed but I also think New England
combining that with offensively a group
that wants to get downhill on you try
and punch you in the mouth between the
tackles and make use of all those tight
end bodies around Mac Jones might have
the best chance of that group to try and
get one over
all right you heard it here first he
likes it Patriots we'll see if that age
as well we've got a few of those teams
playing today that have Super Bowl
aspirations though the bills have
struggled as of late the Cowboys have
played very well the Vikings also are
having a strong season if you had to
place a Super Bowl bet on one of those
three Mike who do you got
yeah you know what I think we're gonna
see a pattern here I'd probably still
lean the bills I know they've been
banged up in key areas at different
times of the Season losing Poirier for
parts time in the secondary Tremaine
Edmonds missed list last week at
linebacker but I think when that defense
gets on the field and healthy it's one
of the most impactful in the NFL and I
know Josh Allen some of the recent Red
Zone turnovers have been a little bit
alarming but I still think the talent on
that offense the quarterback when he is
right I think he'll get back to getting
right possibly against this defense uh
coming up on Thanksgiving I think that
can still be the team that's most
dangerous even in an AFC playoff picture
that's got some real dynamite up top
we're gonna move to QB's now because
we've got some really fun ones that are
playing today who do you think will
throw for the most passing yards today
Alan Goff Jones doc Mac or Kirk
uh I'm probably gonna go back to the
bills for this one and say Josh Allen I
I love the Lions and what they've been
able to do in this three-game win streak
but they haven't seen a passing offense
with as much talent or as much Firepower
as the one Buffalo is getting ready to
trot in
um I think the Lions dead last in yards
per attempt allowed two through the air
on defense so this might be one of those
get right spots for this Buffalo offense
and I think Josh Allen can have a really
big day
I'm with you on that one we'll see how
it goes but you know we talked football
we had to but we cannot leave without
asking you some Thanksgiving food
questions so the first question for you
turkey are we going underrated or
overrated
I'll say overrated it's been the face of
the holiday for a long time now I have
been encouraged in recent years my ham
family has been showing up in more Force
arguing for its place as a Thanksgiving
Protein that's deserving of recognition
I think it's weird when we partner
pardon the turkeys every year before you
know they meet their untimely demise and
so I'll go turkey overrated right now I
understand people that deep fry it
really love that I have had deep fried
turkey it's wonderful I just think in
general we're talking about a slightly
overrated holiday meat very overrated
I've had the deep fried to it all it all
tastes the same but which Thanksgiving
side if we're moving on from the turkey
when it comes to the sides what
Thanksgiving side is the MVP which one
do you like best I I probably go mac and
cheese I think when it's done really
well and even when it's not done well
mac and cheese is incredible because
it's really hard to find a bad version
of it but Thanksgiving you're pulling
out all the stops Grandma's probably
putting some of the crumbles on top of
that thing you're oven baking it it's
got textures Galore it just adds so much
to a given plate you got great teammates
on the plate mashed potatoes the great
locker room guy good binding agent I
would say sweet potato casseroles a
dessert is awesome green bean casserole
is a staple it's like your o-line it's
sturdy it's in the mix stuffings right
in that mold too but mac and cheese has
a real chance to be an explosive
playmaker for you on the Thanksgiving
plate and especially if those
breadcrumbs are involved but last one
for you Mike odds you take a post meal
nap I put that one at like minus a
thousand is that one a lock
Immortal lock and it's vital take care
of yourselves Thanksgiving is about
spending time with family making sure we
all tell people what we're thankful for
and recognize all the good things we
have in life it's also about taking care
of yourself it's a long day of football
it's a long day of eating at some point
you got to break it up stop talking
politics with your relatives for a
little bit give yourself a break and
enjoy a nice nap in your comfiest
sweatpants you've earned it you're
absolutely right look it's always fun to
have you join us Mike thanks so much for
being here and have a great Thanksgiving
thanks for having me have a Happy
Thanksgiving
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]